joining us now is the attorney for
president trump lindsey halligan is with
us
i want to very specifically are there
other items that you can name besides
the passports that were taken that
should never have been taken
that's the thing we don't know exactly
what they took we've asked multiple
times for a real inventory
description of what was taken
but the inventory list they gave us is
borderline worthless it doesn't say
where the documents were located what
specifically was taken
now we know they seized his passports
two of which were expired and they gave
them to his attorneys today
so he'll have them soon but we have real
concerns in terms of whether they were
right to take certain things
the department of justice is not
communicating with us as to what the
evidence
is and what their intentions are but we
will continue to try to get to the
bottom of it the department of justice
clearly has different rules for
donald trump than anyone else out there
the whole system truly does suffer when
they write different rules for different
people
why were you and another attorney of the
president denied access to watch what
was going on and who specifically were
they asking to turn off the surveillance
footage
they didn't give us a reason
for preventing us from going inside the
property i even tried to get in the
property just for sake of air
conditioning because it was like 95
degrees outside and they were there from
10 a.m to 6 30 i think
but they wouldn't even let me stand
inside the property where they weren't
searching
they asked
president trump and i think his managers
to
turn off the surveillance
which they didn't
right
okay we appreciate you being with us
thank you so much president trump
lindsey thank you hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else